Hello Freak bitches.
He did.
We did because we support each other.
We sure did and do all my record comes out August 11th that's my birthday.
He's a really
is like an old man.
You want to come to my release on August 10 in la?
You are welcome.
All right.
Shit.
I don't have a release date.
I got get my shit together.
Get shade.
A beautiful record.
Made a fucking awesome.
Listen man.
Oh Jesus.
You want to do that pressure?
Getting deep here.
I couldn't.
I'm not ready.
I couldn't possibly
like,
oh,
you're not going to play on it.
Okay,
here we go.
Okay.
You can do the instrumental.
What's his car?
It's called everlasting peace,
so shit.
Oh Shit.
Here we go.
Some days I'll wake up in a sweat bodies wet from the teaching baby
with all these cheap thrills from tangible achievements weighing heavy on my
Amy,
it's like a path.
I'll walk,
lift me up like daytime talk like a Reno Rock and sing it to you
straight from the heart.
Fi Fi
there'd be a violin solo,
but we don't have the violin.
Right.
We'll skip that.
I say it till,
I don't mean
don't want to come from my,
I
don't want to lose myself in some days,
but no,
no.
Show me
Pee,
pee.
You guys have such a good sound.
Again,
it's two people that were working at it for a long time.
What time?
You got to know each other's sound?
Make difference.
How'd you mess it up?
Oh,
you know,
it's new stuff.
It's like it's going to shut up.
Set that map and open it up with singing.
Okay.
[inaudible].